hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to mr hopps playhouse 2.
the demo if you remember mr hop's play
house it went a little bit like this
god and this is the demo for the sequel
that the developer has been working very
hard
on which i'm happy to play
hello hello do i have a mirrors
would love to play this game would love
to play it now
i think i've broken it i think i've
broken
wow there's my mouse okay i got a mouse
now
now we're gonna play moonbit
this game contains scary themes flashing
visuals and jump scares
player discretion is advised feel it
you feel that you feel the ominousness
you feel childhood toys coming to life
in horrifying ways
you feel nightmares where your whole
family gets murdered by a giant bunny
it's going to happen well maybe anyway
let's play
i don't know how much of the demo there
is but i'm eager
to see what new horrors line store
just as i was okay
really setting the tone here oh
well this is strange keep your noise
level low to avoid danger
i remember bam what's gonna happen if i
make noise
what's gonna happen hello
hi hello is this a bed
it's a very strange it's kind of like
the amnesia house
okay oh
i gotta hold it okay that's gonna be
important lesson that i'm going to die
many times
doing wrong i have to hold it
shift
did i see something in the door just me
being crazy
oh yeah just me being crazy push push
esther why did i need to push that
i don't remember there being multiple
floors in the previous version of this
something's going to chase me down this
hallway something's going to chase me no
no
all right here we go definitely nothing
to the left here
hi hello hi bunny oh no don't give up
okay oh there's nowhere to go
we are trying to sleep okay whatever
black lands manor orphanage united
kingdom 1952.
all up again did you have a bad dream
again esther
it's not just a bad dream isaac it's the
same dream
over and over again maybe it
means something maybe it means you're
going crazy
i am not crazy here you are
kids more things for you to make a mess
with
new toys and that's kind of what kids do
right
where's the clown of a gun the clown
have a gun
oh boy oh wow okay all right
hey i've seen this before
yeah these are quite creepy looking no
they're not
they're adorable i'm going to call mine
miss bo i'll call mine mr stripes
what are you going to call your bester
oh
mr hobb
right okay good this is how things go
good
this is great love this style by the way
love this style
love this style hey fellow children hey
what's up fellow youngsters this is me
here
probably like a ten-year-old girl maybe
nine eight
i don't know i don't know ages anyway
anybody want to play
with my new toy bunny
mr hump no okay all right later guys
see you around be around i can duck
i don't know what good that'll do me hey
it doesn't seem to be any noise here
yep nope all right
okay okay
esther down here okay
one second i gotta make sure i my
completionist
senses are tingling i gotta make sure i
know the lay of the land before i do
absolutely anything
hey there's a crack in the wall hey
there's a giant knight
there hey this place is kind of big
the hell is going on here what kind of
orphanage is this
i hate those hallways i hate the ominous
empty hallways
how big is this place what in the heck
in hell
wait where where did i go where am i
what happened
hello no yes oh my god okay i'm coming
hang on
where where why are so many creepy
statues this is like the fanciest
orphanage i've ever seen in my life
this is kind of ridiculous where are you
guys
marco ho ho
marco s uh opus
oppos oh
nice nice
okay well that was a dead end i went the
wrong way
this house is freaking huge
ah lexie and throwing a jump scare to
keep them on their toes
uh finally do you want to play hide and
seek with us
that wouldn't be fair you can see
esther's big head from anywhere
hey are so funny molly don't forget
beautiful and clever
you go count by the lift we will hide in
the library there's a lift
there's a levator in here yeah also
don't make fun of people with big heads
it means they got giant brains not that
you would understand this list had been
out of order for two weeks please
telephone an engineer
sure an orphanage has an elevator two
one coming ready or not mr hop
you wait here uh maybe maybe not the
best idea
maybe not the best idea oh i'm close to
my objective
apparently
oh hi oh this is good
oh this is good
anybody here anybody
here i'm assuming i need to push this
for something
like a book
okay what good did that do me
okay that didn't do me no good there's a
strange book there
that this one seems to be out of place a
bit
something clicked something clicked
i heard that ready or not i'm gonna find
you
i'm gonna find someone oh
you are not fair not fair
that's how the game works i need to hide
better you need to stop being such a 2d
creature
yeah what was that all about with the
freaking bookshelf
oh hi you weren't there before as usual
i was the best at hiding no i don't
think you're allowed to move to
different hiding
spots it's not fun playing with a cheat
i cheat
you are lucky i am even playing with you
right now
can we please keep the noise down don't
you know this is a library
yes miss beverly awful children
it's not like anybody else is in here we
can go somewhere else
i'll go get mr hop yeah okay i'll go get
mr hop
i'm sure mr hop is still gonna be there
all right lexie and play that back
[Music]
i still don't know what it was play it
back in my eyes right now
i don't know your powers are getting
weak hi mr pepsi i must have left you
too close to the edge
yeah sure we'll justify it with that
well well this oh okay
hi hey hi
[Music]
yeah all the other kids are you there is
that you sleeping
don't like the others i'll try not to
damn it damn it
damn it good thing they're such sound
sleepers
[Music]
i'm sorry matrons are patrolling the
halls avoid being caught by being
hiding and keeping look wait trends
matrons it's a matron
hello matron how are you doing
hi have you seen mr hop okay oh my god
what are you doing i'm going i'm going
okay good
good good good good good good excellent
this is excellent
this is excellent i don't know what the
hell i'm doing but this is
excellent hi
anybody here h h
all vinyl records are to be returned
here please
matron muriel okay matron
muriel whatever you say matrimony ariel
can i get up on this no not yet but i
can't no no
oh my god a threat is by the door
of threats is by the door everybody of
threats is by the door i please
could i please get up could i get up i
can't get up
oh you won't let me get it no like it's
still just a demo
okay a threat to by the door you say
hey
i don't know where i'm going i'm
assuming maybe back to the library but
i'm not 100 sure about that
a laborer it's the only other place i've
ever been
so just assuming
she saw that weird minecraft book
creeper book
it did a thing it definitely clicked
but why no nothing
all right sure then sure let's go with
sure
t well i wish i could have gotten the h
maybe i couldn't have gotten the h until
i got the t
okay oh matron
matron no no
no oh
am i dead i was caught trying dammit
all right well new objective added
what is it oh there's a oh i forgot that
there's like a thing
oh that's very handy how far are you
going
[Music]
you never saw a thing
at least i can see oh
oh that's a mouse where are the muses
okay well it definitely was off to the
right don't know what to do about that
though
what's with the mises uh matron can you
can you just can you just
can you just can you
could you oh it is down below
okay well now i know now i can get down
there
oh i'm making a lot of
what noise the hell okay
i'm just gonna go for it it's in the
door there this is definitely in the
door there
oh yeah oh no
it's fine hey what's up
mr hop hey how you doing
please clean up after yourselves if you
use the kitchen thank you
well that's awfully nice we get to cook
our own meals
how did you get all the way down here oh
did you get all the way down here
that's what i would like to know
what's magic go back to the children's
room okay i'm going home now
i'm going to bed oh hello
i don't know what you're playing at
esther
if i catch you out of bed again you'll
be spending the night in the cellar
do i make myself clear yes miss beverly
yes ms bill really big now yes ms
beverly
sorry ms beverly i apologize miss
beverly i really apologize sincerely
sorry sorry miss beverly
i apologize i'm sorry
the six the six what the the six
the six what the six of what the six
what
well i'm alone oh
that's fine the night light looks really
weird are there any night lights that
they make that are just a pair of eyes
staring at me
never mind i'm sorry
hi hey what's up hey how you doing
okay yeah that's fine that's fine
oh eyeball hi
hi ball
weird spikes on the ground that's fine
oh i feel the
power of demons oh that's not good
that's bad
that's bad that's bad bad sounds bad
sounds
[Music]
bad sounds bad bad
oh my god
oh my god whom again
[Music]
why
i just went in a big ass circle why did
i do that i have no idea
oh who did what to who
oh my god oh my god oh my god okay this
is this is where mr hop really starts to
play
and i don't like it i don't know
there we go what do we got here hey
wash my hands i guess i don't have any
objectives so i guess i just got to go
by the sounds
no the sounds are him oh oh
yeah that was ah
[Music]
i'm not sure how healthy i'd be if that
happened to me
[Music]
this is fine all good
wow
what what who did that
why how did you okay where was it is
over to the right here
yeah maximum noise
[Music]
just looking in this place
oh god my poor feet
okay nice oh hi hey what's up pal
[Music]
hey what's up pal
okay okay
oh big fist
big fist ow god i keep owing
[Music]
hi hi friend
well this is fun
[Music]
oh god i'm one no
okay so i just need to not get hit
at all because i keep doing that
hey look here it is okay isn't here no
okay good oh that's not oh
god what do i oh my god uh oh god what
do i do
yeah yeah yeah
can i go home now i hear him he's a
coming
he's a common he's a common he comes
he's coming
he's not coming okay
nice it's probably all the way down the
bottom
i imagine how okay he's coming
he's moving okay i'm gonna go the other
way screw that guy
screw that guy screw that guy
big screw that guy energy
ow now yes yes you do whatever you want
to do it's not going to affect me
all right pal you fool
you fool you thought that was my oh but
it's all the way down the bottom
i bet i betty bet i bet bed bed
ow why am i an idiot no it's not about
them
oh my camera died my camera died
what but you're plugging in okay well um
give me give me a minute give me a
minute i got i got another battery
i'm a professional there i am okay
hey something's on fire oh
how did the what
that wasn't there before there was never
a basement here
i need to put this fire out before the
whole house is burnt down
i guess i need to put fire out what are
these symbols that i got
what's with the symbols hi
they're like a fire extinguisher
do they have those in 1952 hope i don't
touch anything because i'm one hit away
from death
[Music]
we really anti-climb how do i put the
fire out then
hello is it a bug oh no
don't tell me oh because it feels like
there should be something
in the cabinet like there would be like
you know under the sink or something
like that
oh no oh no it feels like there should
be something there
but maybe not maybe not
oh it oh and then i go to the sink
ah perfect it's not a bug ah there's no
fire extinguishers in 1952 i should have
known
all right i got the water oh man i'm
quick with a bucket of water look at me
go
sploosh literally
nice what is oh
hey guys what do those symbols mean and
why do i keep seeing them
come on maybe because you're weird
hello all you fellow children i'm
running out the door
running away from this place what's my
objective oh hey what's going on molly
you put mr hop in the kitchen last night
and got me in trouble
what that wasn't me why would i go
anywhere near
mr hop when i have miss bo are you sure
you weren't just sleepwalking
you know maybe if you didn't act like
such a princess and tried to be nice
we all might actually like you
[Music]
what do you mean well then again you
should go apologize
when what what
well i don't wanna what if i don't wanna
why is it this way
what's going on here i'll probably just
down below all right
fine go just because some people can
help a little
handle a little criticism doesn't mean
that i need to go apologize
a bunch of baloney good thing i have a
radar in my head that tells me exactly
where everyone is
we're all microchipped here
[Music]
why is it so ominous oh that's why it
was so ominous
it was a portal to the nether the nether
of hell
well this is probably hey miss bo hang
on
whoa okay all right that's weird
that's gonna scar me that is gonna be
dramatic
hey what's up mr stripes okay
all right cool wow this is great
hey what's up mr hop okay
oh
who's laughing at me who would they
i knew it was this demo and still i
really liked it really like
i love the styling the acting was good
too like the voice acting was quite
quite quality and uh just like something
about the atmosphere of it i mean
like obviously the the segment with the
platforming was
just like platforming um but just like
when it's there and you're just a kid
hiding in the hallways like i love that
style i love that style
this is really cool can't wait for the
full version to come out on steam
apparently
and uh thank you to moon big games and
the developer of this game for
making something really special here
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below and if you want to see
the original mr hop
i'll put that link in the description or
you can just search for it on youtube
you can find it
on my channel or on youtube in general
mr ops playhouse markiplier something
like that
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always i'll see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]